now we all think that um alzheimer's is a
brain problem that starts in the brain right it
starts in the brain and then it develops in the
brain and it's not connected to any other part
but i found some real interesting data that shows
that alzheimer's actually originates in your liver
the liver has a function of clearing out
something called amyloid b plaques and so
the liver should normally clear this out so
it doesn't spread into other parts of your
body but when the liver is compromised and it
can't do that whether you have a fatty liver
you have cirrhosis you have inflammation you
have diabetes you have metabolic syndrome
whatever then the liver is going to have a very
very hard time getting rid of that plaquing and
then it starts developing in the brain but you
you won't have symptoms for roughly about 20 years
then you start getting the dementia so it's a
process and the problem is that a lot of times
people are waiting until they get a symptom
before they do anything about it but i want to
emphasize this very very important connection
that you need to know about especially if you
want to prevent alzheimer's so what can you
do well number one take care of your liver
right i have a lot of videos on this i'll put
some links down below very very important but
let's say for example you're already starting
to get dementia you start going in a room you
can't quite remember why you went in there and you
start losing your keys and you just start having
memory loss you're getting a little bit older and
you're concerned what you need to do is start to
support your liver immediately well there's
a couple things you can do there's actually
four really important things to do and so these
few articles down below cover these points
and i think it's actually quite fascinating bile
salts specifically a type of biosolid called tudka
has the ability to decrease amyloid plaquing and
amyloid clearing in the hippocampus which is the
part of the brain that is involved with the relay
to your database or remembering certain things
especially spatial memory and by the way if
you go on a low fat diet your bio salts dry up
also if you destroy your gut you're not going to
be able to make bile salts because your body makes
secondary bile salts from the microbes in your
gut that's one of the reasons why there's a big
connection between your gut and your brain
what's going on down here is affecting up
here number two vitamin d and by the way if you
don't have bile salts or not enough bile salts
you're not going to be able to absorb vitamin
d so there's a big connection between vitamin
d and clearing out amyloid plaquing also
vitamin d is very very important in the liver
and the liver is part of the process
where the vitamin d gets activated
it's also an organ that you help store vitamin
d but vitamin d is very very important all
right number three silly marin that's milk
thistle has the capacity to clear out amyloid
plaquing so if you're getting dementia or you
have alzheimer's you should be taking all these
including the next point which is intermittent
fasting intermittent fasting helps clear out the
amyloid plaquing why because your body starts
to perform autophagy which is a recycling
of proteins that you don't need and you'd have
to do at least 18 hours of fasting to get into
autophagy but very very important if you want
to clear out these proteins all right thanks
for watching hey before you go real quick i have
a course entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why here's you here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over
here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and resist
your environment much better by strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today